Did you know that parents rank financial literacy as the number one most difficult life skill to teach? Meet Greenlight, the debit card and money app for families. With Greenlight, you can send money to kids instantly, set up chores, automate allowance, and keep an eye on your kids' spending with real-time notifications. Kids get to earn, save, and spend wisely, and parents can rest easy, knowing their kids are learning about money with guardrails in place. Sign up for Greenlight today at Greenlight.com slash Odyssey. Miami Metro catches killers, and they say it takes a village to race one. Anyone knows how powerful urges can be? It's me. Catch Dexter Morgan in a new serial killer origin story. Hunger inside of you. It needs a master.
你知道父母将金融素养列为最难教给孩子的生活技能第一名吗？来认识一下 Greenlight，专为家庭设计的借记卡和理财应用。通过 Greenlight，你可以即时向孩子们汇款、安排家务、自动发放零花钱，并通过实时通知随时关注孩子们的消费情况。孩子们学会明智地赚钱、储蓄和消费，而父母也能高枕无忧，因为他们知道孩子在有安全保障的情况下学习理财。今天就登录 Greenlight.com/Odyssey 注册 Greenlight 吧。迈阿密警局负责抓捕杀手，而他们说培养一个孩子需要全村之力。谁知道强烈的冲动能有多大力量？就是我。在全新的连环杀手起源故事中看德克斯特·摩根。你心中的饥饿感。它需要一个主人。
Featuring Patrick Gibson, Christian Slater, special guest star Sarah Michelle Geller, with Patrick Densey and Michael C. Hall as Dexter's inner voice. I wasn't born a killer. I was made. Dexter Original Sin, new series streaming December 13th, exclusively on Paramount Plus, a mountain of entertainment. -♪ I'm Jenna Fisher.
由帕特里克·吉布森、克里斯蒂安·史莱特、特邀明星莎拉·米歇尔·盖勒主演，帕特里克·邓西和迈克尔·C·霍尔饰演德克斯特的内心独白。我生来不是杀人犯。我是被塑造出来的。德克斯特：原始罪孽，12月13日全新剧集独家上线 Paramount Plus，汇聚万千精彩。-♪ 我是珍娜·费舍尔。
And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details, and lots of VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello. Hi there. FF Stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0.
我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量 VFF 故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妈 6.0。你好。嗨。FF 故事。我们是办公室辣妈 6.0。
Hello. Hi there. We are so excited because today we get to share our interview with Kathy Bates. Kathy Flippin' Bates. We got to Zoom with Kathy Bates, lady. I'm still kinda pinching myself about it. I still, yeah, me too. Like even afterwards I was like, we just spent over an hour.
你好。嗨。我们太兴奋了，因为今天我们可以分享对凯西·贝茨的采访。凯西·绝配·贝茨。我们和凯西·贝茨进行了 Zoom 连线，女士。我到现在还觉得像是在掐自己确认这不是做梦。我还是，对，我也是。甚至结束后我还觉得，我们刚刚聊了一个多小时。
Yeah. We talked for so long. With Kathy Bates. Yes. You guys know that Kathy Bates appeared in eight episodes of The Office over seasons six and seven. She was Sabre's CEO, Joe Bennett, and she shares some really fun memories about her time on the show.
对。我们聊了那么久。和凯西·贝茨。是的。大家知道凯西·贝茨在《办公室》第六季和第七季中客串了八集。她扮演了莎布雷的首席执行官乔·贝内特，她分享了一些关于她在该剧拍摄期间非常有趣的回忆。
I mean, you know, she's just a legend. We are so fortunate that we got to work with her, have this amazing conversation with her. She has won an Academy Award, two Emmy Awards, two Golden Globe Awards, and two Screen Actors Guild Awards. She is currently starring in the new CBS series, Matlock. It's a huge hit, and I'm sure she's gonna add more awards to that shelf. Oh, for sure. I love Matlock. Me too! We both started watching it! We've been watching it! It is so good!
我的意思是，你知道，她简直是个传奇。我们非常幸运能与她合作，并与她进行这次精彩的对话。她曾获得过奥斯卡奖、两座艾美奖、两座金球奖和两座美国演员工会奖。她目前正在主演 CBS 的全新剧集《老练律师》。这是一部巨大的热门剧集，我相信她的奖杯架上一定会添更多的奖项。哦，那是肯定的。我喜欢《老练律师》。我也是！我们两个都开始看了！我们一直在看！真的太棒了！
It had me from the minute, like that first scene in the coffee shop. Oh my gosh. The pilot is one of the best pilots I've seen. I told her that too. Yeah. Well, we want to share a little bit about her new series. Kathy Bates plays a wealthy retired lawyer named Madeline Kingston, and she returns to practicing law as a way to seek justice for the death of her daughter,
从第一分钟起就吸引了我，就像咖啡馆里的那个第一场戏。哦天哪。试播集是我看过最好的试播集之一。我也这么告诉过她。对。嗯，我们想分享一些关于她的新剧的信息。凯西·贝茨饰演一位名叫玛德琳·金斯顿的富有退休律师，她重操旧业，以此为女儿伸张正义，
Ellie, who died as a result of the opioid epidemic. But now you don't find that out to the end. Of the pilot. Yeah. Yes, that's right. When we meet her, we meet her in her fake identity as a sort of like needy widow named Maddie Matlock. Who had like a crappy ex-husband.
艾莉因阿片类药物流行而丧生。但你直到最后才发现这一点。试播集的结尾。对。是的，没错。当我们见到她时，她正以假身份出现，仿佛是一个名叫麦迪·马特洛克的需要关怀的寡妇。她有一个糟糕的前夫。
Yes, and she's raising her grandson on her own. And she is raising her grandson on her own and she is raising her grandson but not on her own because her husband's still living. Stay with me. And her husband is nice. And her husband is great. Stay with us. And she gets a job at the law firm that she believes has hid evidence that could have saved her daughter's life. Mm-hmm and the whole pilot is sort of her sneaking her way into the law firm. And she ends up in the big conference room meeting,
是的，她独自抚养她的孙子。她独自抚养她的孙子，而且她独自抚养她的孙子，但也不是独自抚养，因为她丈夫还活着。听我解释。而且她丈夫很好。而且她丈夫很棒。跟我们一起听下去。她找到了一份工作，在一家她认为隐藏了本可以救她女儿命的证据的律所工作。嗯哼，整个试播集基本上就是她潜入律所的过程。最后她进了大型会议室开会，
and she blows them away. It's a very bad ass moment. And they decide to give her like a two weeks temporary hire to see how she's going to shake out. Yeah, kind of test run. So she's in. She's very excited. I just loved this conference room scene.
她惊艳了所有人。这是一个非常霸气的时刻。他们决定给她两周的试用期，看看她表现如何。对，算是一次测试。所以她留下了。她非常兴奋。我太喜欢这个会议室的场景了。
They're all having this meeting, and they're in litigation with this other company and they're trying to figure out like, what would this company be willing to settle at? What would they be willing to settle at? And all of a sudden, like from the back of the room, you hear her be like, I know the number they're willing to settle at and I'll tell you what it is if you give me a job. And everyone's like, who is this lady? Right. Where did she come from? And then she goes on to explain how she found out
他们都在开会，他们正在和另一家公司打官司，他们试图弄清楚，这家公司愿意接受多少时间和解？他们愿意接受多少和解金额？突然之间，就像从房间后面传来的声音，你听到她说：“我知道他们愿意接受的和解金额，只要你给我一份工作，我就告诉你。”每个人都像是在想，这女士是谁？对。她是从哪儿冒出来的？接着她开始解释她是如何发现
the number they're willing to settle for and it's much higher than this law firm thought. I actually thought we should listen because I loved it so much. Yeah, it's a great scene. Here it is. Let's avoid traps then. How do you know the number?
他们愿意接受的和解金额，而且比这家律所想象的要高得多。其实我觉得我们应该听听，因为我太喜欢了。对，这是一场精彩的戏。就是这样。那我们来避开陷阱吧。你怎么知道这个数字的？
Well, you see, there's this funny thing that happens when women age. We become damn near invisible. Oh, not that I'm complaining. I had my moment in the sun. Plus it's useful because nobody sees us coming. That's how I got through your security several times. And it's also how I knew that Peabody's counsel grabs coffee and updates his client between 815 and 825.
嗯，你知道，女人上年纪后会发生一件很有趣的事。我们变得几乎隐形了。哦，倒不是我在抱怨。我也曾有过高光时刻。而且这很有用，因为没人会注意到我们的接近。这就是我怎么好几次溜过你们安保的。这也是我怎么知道皮博迪的法律顾问在 8:15 到 8:25 之间去买咖啡并向他的客户汇报的。
What's the number? Am I hired? No one is hired without a two week trial. What's their ceiling? 23 million, which means I just made you $4 million. Do I still need a two week trial? It's so good. So good. But I think what I like about the show is how, you know, people doubting you or people
数字是多少？我被录用了吗？没有两周试用期，谁都不会被录用。他们的心理上限是多少？2300 万，这意味着我刚刚帮你们赚了 400 万美元。我还需要两周试用期吗？太棒了。太棒了。但我觉得我喜欢这部剧的地方在于，你知道，当人们怀疑你或者人们
not believing in you or people not seeing you, like, that can be really hard, but you can also turn it to your advantage. Yeah. And make it work for you. And I really like that. You know, there's a thing about this character that reminded me of something Phyllis said to you. Yes!
不相信你，或者人们看不到你时，这确实很难，但你也可以把它变成你的优势。是的。并为自己所用。我真的很喜欢这一点。你知道，这个角色的某个特点让我想起了菲莉丝对你说过的话。对！
Years ago. Yes, me too. Yeah, she knew all the scoop happening on the set. She always knew all the best gossip. All the best gossip, but she wasn't a gossip. She was not chatty. She did not share it. And Jenna has shared this before on the podcast,
多年前。是的，我也是。是的，她知道片场发生的所有内幕消息。她总是知道所有最好的八卦。所有最好的八卦，但她并不是个八卦的人。她不爱唠叨。她不会到处宣扬。珍娜之前在播客里分享过这个，
but one time Jenna was like, Phyllis how do you know everything? And she goes well when you're invisible you know people say stuff around you. She's like I think people don't notice me. Yeah. So I hear it all. Yeah. Well Angela you have a Matlock fun fact to share with us. I do. Rainn Wilson and Melora Hardin both guest-starred in the original Matlock series and Linda Pearl aka Helene Beasley played Charlene Matlock in 23 episodes of the original series. A little office Matlock connection there. Yeah. Well something else about Kathy Bates is that she and I are both breast cancer survivors.
但有一次珍娜问：“菲莉丝，你怎么什么都知道？”她说，嗯，当你是隐形人的时候，你知道别人会在你身边说些什么。她说我觉得人们注意不到我。是的。所以我什么都听得到。是的。好吧，安吉拉，你有一个关于《老练律师》的有趣事实要和我们分享。我有。雷恩·威尔逊和梅洛拉·哈丁都曾在原版《老练律师》系列中客串过，而琳达·珀尔（也就是海伦·比斯利）在原版剧集的 23 集里扮演了夏琳·马特洛克。这算是一个小小的办公室与《老练律师》的联动。是的。对了，关于凯西·贝茨的另一件事是，她和我都是乳腺癌幸存者。
Kathy is actually a two-time cancer survivor. Kathy was diagnosed with ovarian cancer in 2003 and breast cancer in 2012. After being treated for breast cancer, she developed lymphedema, and she is now the spokesperson of the Lymphatic Education and Research Network, and she talked with us about that as well. I really appreciated getting to talk with her about this. When you are a cancer patient, there's a language that goes with it. I say to my other breast cancer ladies, like, we speak cancer,
凯西其实是一位两次患癌的幸存者。凯西于 2003 年被诊断出患有卵巢癌，2012 年被诊断出患有乳腺癌。在接受乳腺癌治疗后，她患上了淋巴水肿，她现在是淋巴教育与研究网络的代言人，她也跟我们聊了聊这个。我很感激能和她谈论这个。当你是一名癌症患者时，有一套与之相关的语言。我对我的其他乳腺癌姐妹们说，我们讲的是癌症的语言，
and so I got to kind of speak that language with her a little bit and feel, I really heard she was so kind. She was very kind and thoughtful. And one of the biggest takeaways from just getting a chance to talk to her for me was how committed she is to making a difference and helping others. And I really admired her for that. Yeah, I really admire her too. You know, she's talked about this desire to be useful and her character talks about that on Matlock being useful and that's something that I felt with my own journey. If I could just make this somehow useful, it keeps me going. I really identified with that when she talked about that. But guys, it was just an honor to have worked with her and to have her on the podcast.
所以我得以和她稍微说了说那种语言，并且感受到，我真的听出来她是那么善良。她非常善良和体贴。对我来说，有机会和她交谈的最大收获之一，就是她对做出改变和帮助他人的执着。我真的很佩服她这一点。是的，我也真的很佩服她。你知道，她谈到过想要发挥作用的愿望，她的角色在《老练律师》中也谈到了要发挥作用，这也是我在自己的康复之旅中所感受到的。如果我能以某种方式让这一切发挥作用，它就会支撑我继续前进。当她谈到这一点时，我真的很有共鸣。但是伙计们，能和她合作并请她上我们的播客，简直是莫大的荣幸。
We're going to take a quick break and then our interview with Kathy Bates. This segment is brought to you by Macy's. Hey everyone, this is your friendly reminder that the holiday season is upon us. Macy's is our one-stop shop for gifting this season. I have found gifts for everyone on my list thanks to the Macy's Gift Guide. In fact, it was their gift guide titled Home that helped me find the perfect gift for my sister this year. They have such good gift guides. Lady, I'm so excited that we partnered with them this
我们先休息一下，接下来是采访凯西·贝茨。本环节由梅西百货为您呈献。嘿大家好，这是对大家的温馨提醒，假日季已经来临。梅西百货是我们这个季节一站式挑选礼物的好去处。多亏了梅西百货的送礼指南，我在清单上的每个人都找到了礼物。事实上，正是他们名为“家居”的送礼指南，帮我找到了今年送给我妹妹的完美礼物。他们的送礼指南真是太棒了。女士，我很高兴我们能在这个
holiday season because they are truly actually making my holiday shopping so much easier. Because I have spent so much time with the gift guides. So what did you get your sister? I got her an air fryer. Great. And I know she's gonna be excited about it because she recently told me that her kids new favorite thing to make at home are pan-fried potatoes, but it drives her crazy because of how the oil splatters all over the stove when they make it. Because I think they like to make it, but they don't love to clean it up, I guess. Well, that's usually the case, right?
假日季与他们合作，因为他们真的让我的节日购物变得轻松多了。因为我在送礼指南上花了太多时间。那你给你妹妹买什么了？我给她买了一个空气炸锅。太棒了。我知道她一定会很兴奋，因为她最近告诉我，她孩子们现在最喜欢在家做的是煎土豆片，但这快把她逼疯了，因为他们做的时候油会溅得到处都是。因为我觉得他们喜欢做，但大概不太喜欢收拾吧。嗯，通常情况都是这样，对吧？
Anyway, I don't think I would have thought of an air fryer, but I saw it pop up on the gift guide. Well, speaking of gift guides, we also started our own Macy's gift guide where we are putting our picks for the holidays. So Jenna, I know you added the air fryer to our list. I did, because I think it's such a fun thing. It's kind of like a toy for adults. I feel like it's something you might not buy yourself,
不管怎样，我本来可能不会想到空气炸锅，但我在送礼指南上看到了它弹出来。嗯，说到送礼指南，我们还推出了我们自己的梅西百货送礼指南，我们在上面放了我们挑选的节日好物。所以珍娜，我知道你把空气炸锅加到了我们的清单里。我加了，因为我觉得这真是个有趣的东西。它有点像成年人的玩具。我觉得这可能是那种你不会自己买，
but you would love as a gift. Yeah. I have one too, I love it. Give love, give an air fryer. You're gonna put a swipe up in our stories too, right? For sure. In general, I love small kitchen appliances. I love a blender, a mini food processor, a rice cooker. That is my personal favorite. I'm going to add a rice cooker to our gift guide. cookers so much. Well, I added a few things to our gift guide as well. So my son has really been wanting a pair of nice slippers. You know, he had like his little kids slippers,
但作为礼物你会非常喜欢的。对。我也有一个，我太喜欢了。送出爱意，送上空气炸锅。你也会在我们的快拍里放一个上滑链接吧？当然。总的来说，我喜欢小型厨房电器。我喜欢搅拌机、迷你食物料理机、电饭煲。那是我的个人最爱。我要把电饭煲加到我们的送礼指南里。太喜欢电饭煲了。嗯，我也往我们的送礼指南里加了一些东西。我儿子一直很想要一双漂亮的拖鞋。你知道，他以前有那种小孩穿的小拖鞋，
you know, like the fuzzy ones and they've fallen apart, but he's older now, he's a teenager, and he wanted some cozy slippers, but like also ones that you could walk out in the driveway in. Yep. So I got him these great Ugg slippers. They are the Ugg Men's Classic Slip-On Shaggy Suede slippers.
你知道的，毛茸茸的那种，已经穿烂了，但他现在长大了，是个青少年了，他想要一双舒服的拖鞋，但也得是那种能穿着走到车道上的那种。对。所以我给他买了一双很棒的 Ugg 拖鞋。那是 Ugg 男士经典一脚蹬毛绒麂皮拖鞋。
I can't wait to give them to him. And I added a little something for me on our site. What did you add? Well, I mean, I love to dress best of this time of year. So I added a cute red sweater, and on the front of it in white, it Mary M-E-R-R-Y. That is so you. It's by CC and I put it on our storefront so you know people who are like me and want to be festive can go there and get it.
我等不及要把它送给他了。我在我们的网站上也给自己加了一点小东西。你加了什么？嗯，我是说，我喜欢在这个时候把自己打扮得喜庆一点。所以我加了一件可爱的红毛衣，正面用白色写着 M-E-R-R-Y（圣诞快乐）。太符合你的风格了。这是 CC 品牌的，我把它放到了我们的网店上，所以像我这样想要有节日气氛的人都可以去那里买。
We really hope you'll check out our gift list. We have put so much love and care into it. And at Macy's Friends and Family you can take an extra 30% off top gifts and 50% off top beauty brands. It's Macy's best offer of the season. Take an extra 30% off top gifts plus 15% off our best beauty brands and free shipping starting at $25. Let Macy's be your guide to gifting. Shop our favorites this holiday season directly from our Macy's gift guide storefront by visiting the link in our Instagram bio. We tried to fill it with lots of ideas from sweet treats to stocking stuffers and more.
我们真的很希望你能去看看我们的礼物清单。我们在上面倾注了太多的爱和心思。在梅西百货的亲友特卖会上，顶级礼物可享受额外的 30% 折扣，顶级美妆品牌可享受 50% 折扣。这是梅西百货本季最好的优惠。顶级礼物额外享受 30% 折扣，外加我们最好的美妆品牌额外 15% 折扣，消费满 25 美元即可免运费。让梅西百货成为你的送礼向导。访问我们 Instagram 个人简介中的链接，直接在我们的梅西百货送礼指南网店选购我们在这个假日季的最爱。我们试图在里面塞满各种点子，从甜点到长筒袜里的惊喜应有尽有。
Again, head to our Instagram bio for the link to shop directly from our Macy's gift guide storefront. Happy shopping! Happy shopping. Hi, how are you? Good. Thank you. Who's this puppy on your lap? This is Zelda. Hi, Zelda.
再次提醒，前往我们的 Instagram 个人简介点击链接，直接从我们的梅西百货送礼指南网店购买。祝你购物愉快！购物愉快。嗨，你好吗？很好。谢谢。你膝盖上这只小狗是谁？这是塞尔达。嗨，塞尔达。
Yeah, she's in a licking mode. I don't know why. Hi, how are you guys? So good. It's so fun to get to see you again after all these years. I know, it's been, let's see, I think I did the show in 11, like 12 years ago. Yeah. Yeah.
对，它现在处于舔人模式。我不知道为什么。嗨，你们好吗？非常好。这么多年后再次见到你们太有趣了。我懂，已经，让我看看，我想我大概是 11 年、大约 12 年前上这个节目的。对。对。
12, 13 years ago. It's been a long time. It's been a long time. A lot of life has happened. Yes, indeed, it has. How are you guys? We're good. We're loving this new job of podcasting.
12、13年前。时间过得真快。时间过得真快。发生了好多事。确实如此。你们好吗？我们很好。我们很喜欢这份做播客的新工作。
Kathy, I only got dressed on the top. Look at this. Just got my pajama pants on the bottom. I didn't even get dressed. I'm still in bed. You are a master podcaster then. Already. And we're basically in our closets here.
凯西，我只穿了上半身衣服。看这个。我下半身还穿着睡裤呢。我甚至还没换衣服。我还躺在床上呢。那你可真是个播客大师了。已经很专业了。我们基本上就是在自己的衣橱里。
This is a closet. I'm in a closet. Oh, I see. That's how we do it. Kathy, thank you so much for joining us today. We are so excited to talk with you about The Office, about your new show, Matlock. We are huge fans of Matlock. Thank you.
这是一个衣橱。我在衣橱里。哦，我明白了。我们就是这么干的。凯西，非常感谢你今天加入我们。我们很高兴能和你聊聊《办公室》，聊聊你的新剧《老练律师》。我们是《老练律师》的超级粉丝。谢谢。
Yes, we are loving it, Kathy. Yeah, and we also wanna talk about your work with the Lymphatic Education and Research Network. Yes. Do you mind if we start with The Office? No, I don't mind at all. Let's begin. Okay. Well. I'll kick us off with our first question
是的，我们太喜欢了，凯西。是的，我们还想聊聊你对淋巴教育与研究网络的支持工作。是的。你介意我们从《办公室》开始聊起吗？不，我不介意。我们开始吧。好的。那我就来抛出我们的第一个问题了，
and it's one we ask all of our guests that were on the office and it's how did you get your job on the office? I think they just offered it to me. I was very lucky. I had not seen the show that much but I watched a great deal of it when I was preparing for the show and everyone was so brilliant and so effortless. You guys, I don't know how you did it. I felt like when I was doing it, I was really running to catch up. And it was a learning curve. I don't know if it was like that for you guys when you started working on the show,
这也是我们对所有上过《办公室》的嘉宾都会问的问题，那就是你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？我想他们只是直接邀请了我。我很幸运。我以前没怎么看过这部剧，但我在为这部剧做准备时看了很多，每个人都那么才华横溢，演得那么游刃有余。伙计们，我不知道你们是怎么做到的。我觉得我在拍的时候，真的在拼命追赶。这是一个学习曲线。我不知道你们刚开始拍这部剧的时候是不是也这样，
but working with their different cameras and the level and the comedy that you guys did, I felt that I was really trying to get the feel of that and trying to do, I always felt after I did an episode that I wasn't sure if I'd really done it the best I could. That's so interesting. I mean, our perspective was that you were nailing it. Like from the get-go. Like when you walked in as Joe Bennett,
但与他们不同的摄像机、拍摄水平以及你们的喜剧风格合作，我觉得我真的在努力寻找那种感觉，并且努力去做到最好。每次拍完一集后，我都觉得不确定自己是不是真的发挥到了最好。太有趣了。我的意思是，我们的看法是你简直太绝了。从一开始就是。就像你作为乔·贝内特走进来的时候，
I would have thought you'd been Joe Bennett your whole life. Oh, really? Yes. Yeah, it was such a fully realized character from the beginning. Wow. Well, I think I was nervous because you guys do the comedy so well, and I don't think of myself as a comedian, and that you worked with the cameras so well.
我会以为你一辈子都是乔·贝内特呢。哦，真的吗？是的。是的，从一开始就是一个非常丰满立体的角色。哇。嗯，我想我当时很紧张，因为你们把喜剧演得太好了，我不认为自己是个喜剧演员，而且你们和摄像机的配合太默契了。
Was that a learning curve for you? I mean, did you, when you started out on it, did you, you had done, when did you start doing it? The camera? Yes. Well, the camera was part of my audition. Yes, same. So from even the audition process, they were wanting me to relate to or not relate to the camera,
这对你来说是一个学习曲线吗？我是说，当你刚开始拍的时候，你有没有，你做过，你是什么时候开始接触这个的？摄像机？对。嗯，摄像机是我试镜的一部分。对，我也是。所以甚至从试镜阶段开始，他们就希望我与摄像机产生互动或不产生互动，
throw looks to the camera. And I just studied the British version to prepare for my audition to watch, because that was such a new idea. And also the idea, not just that you would relate to the camera, but that you would be embarrassed that the camera picked up on something that maybe you didn't want it to. Mm-hmm.
给摄像机抛眼神。为了准备试镜，我特地去研究了英国版的剧集来观看，因为那是一个全新概念。还有那种理念，不仅是你与摄像机会有互动，而且你会因为摄像机捕捉到了你可能不想让它看到的东西而感到尴尬。嗯哼。
Kathy, I remember I was really nervous about how to interact with the camera in our pilot episode. You know, the supporting cast, we were just the background, you know. It was a real lesson in patience and you just had to wait for that moment, you know, when you finally got to have a little interaction. But we spent so much time in the background and my nose was itching so bad one day.
凯西，我记得在我们的试播集中，我对如何与摄像机互动感到非常紧张。你知道，配角们，我们只是背景板，你知道的。这真是耐心的一课，你只需要等待那个时刻，你知道的，当你终于有一点点互动的时候。但我们在背景里待了太久，有一天我的鼻子痒得厉害。
And I thought, oh, I can't scratch it because I'm on camera. That's weird. And I was, oh, God, I wanted to scratch it so bad one day and I thought oh I can't scratch it because I'm on camera that's weird and I was oh god I wanted to scratch it so bad and I went up to Ken Quap as our director and he must have thought I was like so silly I said Ken my nose was really itching in that last take and I scratched it and I'm so sorry and he was like Angela you are living a life, live a life. And the camera captures what it captures. If your nose itches, scratch it. And that was sort of an eye opening moment for me about how to just be in the background. Yeah. One of the episodes that I think I wish I had prepared for first was when Joe comes in and starts talking about the printers. You know, I would like to have gone back and done that and
我想，哦，我不能抓，因为我在镜头前。那多奇怪啊。我当时想，天哪，有一天我太想挠痒痒了，我想，哦，我不能挠，因为我在镜头前，那太奇怪了，我心里想，天哪，我太想挠了，我去找我们的导演肯·夸皮，他当时一定觉得我太傻了，我说，肯，我刚才那条鼻子真的很痒，我抓了，真的非常抱歉，他却说，安吉拉，你在过日子，去过日子吧。镜头捕捉到什么就是什么。你鼻子痒，就去抓。那对如何在背景中好好生活对我来说是一个醍醐灌顶的时刻。有一集我想我真希望自己当时先做好准备，那就是乔进来开始谈论打印机的那一集。你知道的，我希望能回去重新拍一次，
really gone to town with it. But the other ones I really loved working with, I mean, Corel, Steve Corel, I couldn't get over what a fantastic actor and improvisationalist he is. So for me, it was great to be around people like him and John and a whole bunch of the guys and gals. It's just to try and learn from them how they do what they do because it's invisible. Does that make sense? Yeah. Yeah, it does. You don't feel like you're watching someone act when you watch Steve. Like I never do. I always believed him. He just is such a natural in whatever role he puts on. I don't see him acting. I didn't see him as DuPont. Oh in Foxcatcher. That's right. He was nominated for an Academy Award. Yes. Yeah. Yes. I was
并且真正放开手脚去演。但我真的很喜欢和其他演员合作的戏，我是说，卡瑞尔，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我简直不敢相信他是一个多么奇妙的演员和即兴表演者。所以对我和像他、约翰以及其他很多男男女女这样的人在一起，真是太棒了。就是试图从他们身上学习他们是如何做他们所做的事情的，因为那是无形的。这说得通吗？是的。是的，说得通。当你看着史蒂夫时，你不会觉得你在看别人演戏。我从来没有这种感觉。我总是相信他。无论他扮演什么角色，他都表现得那么自然。我看不到他在演戏。我在《狐狸捕手》里也没看出他是杜邦。哦，对。他获得了奥斯卡提名。是的。是的。我当时
watching it with a friend and we were in about 15 minutes and he said, you know who that is? I said, no, who is that? He said, that's Steve Carell. I said, you've got to be kidding me. I can't believe that's Steve Carell. I mean, he was just, he disappeared into the character. But back on working with him at the office, I just wish I could have learned more from him. You know, I certainly enjoyed working on the show. I thought it was a lot of fun. I did have a problem transitioning from lines that were written and then the improvisation that we were allowed to do. I don't know if I ever really succeeded.
正和一个朋友一起看，看了大约15分钟，他说：“你知道那是谁吗？”我说：“不知道，那是谁？”他说：“那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。”我说：“你在跟我开玩笑吧。我不敢相信那是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。”我的意思是，他简直完全融入了这个角色中。但说到在《办公室》里和他合作，我真希望自己能从他身上学到更多。你知道，我确实很享受在这部剧里的工作。我觉得非常有趣。我确实在从写好的台词过渡到我们被允许进行的即兴表演时遇到了一些问题。我不知道我是否真的成功了。
I kept getting tripped up on that. But it was a wonderful experience. I know toward the end, since Steve was leaving, they were interested in me possibly staying on. And I had gone on to do Harry's Law. But, you know, I don't wanna cast aspersions on anybody, but I think it would have been fun to stay on the office. You know?
我一直在这上面磕磕绊绊。但这是一段美好的经历。我知道到最后，由于史蒂夫要离开，他们对让我继续留下来很感兴趣。而我已经去拍《律政俏师太》了。但是，你知道，我不是想对任何人说坏话，但我觉得留在《办公室》里会很有趣。你知道吗？
We would have loved that. We would have loved that. For sure. For sure. And really develop that character more. She had so much. She was so layered. The scenes between Michael and Jo on the private plane were just so brilliant. I loved those. I wanted to see more of her world. Where does she go?
我们会很乐意的。我们会很乐意的。当然。当然。并且真正把那个角色进一步发展下去。她太丰富了。她非常有层次感。迈克尔和乔在私人飞机上的场景简直太精彩了。我太喜欢那些了。我想看更多关于她的世界。她去哪儿了？
And the Great Danes and your outfits and your hair. Were you a part of the look of Joe Bennett? Yeah, I had this fur coat that I had found that was kind of strips of fur that was kind of really kind of low class. But I insisted on wearing that, that it's just so inappropriate. And I think, yes, we worked on the hair and the look for her. And it's been a while, so forgive me. I can't remember the wonderful people who worked with me on that to really create something that was out of style. You know, I think she figured it's what they say when you figure out what style looks good on you, you stay with it regardless of your age or anything or fashion.
还有大丹犬、你的服装和你的发型。你有参与塑造乔·贝内特的造型吗j？是的，我找到了一件皮草大衣，是由一条条皮草拼成的，看起来有点那种很低档的感觉。但我坚持要穿那件，因为那实在太不合时宜了。我想，是的，我们一起为她的发型和造型做出了努力。而且这已经是前不久的事了，请原谅我。我记不清那些和我一起工作、真正创造出这种过时风格的杰出人们的名字了。你知道，我想她大概觉得，这就是人们常说的，当你发现什么风格适合你时，无论你的年龄或时尚潮流如何，你都会坚持下去。
And also just her swagger. You know, I felt she had a lot of swagger and that she was probably a bull in a china shop. That's how she ran her company was just sort of steamrolling over everybody. And with her money. And I loved the Great Danes. I really did. They were great.
还有她那种大摇大摆的气场。你知道，我觉得她很有气场，而且她可能就像瓷器店里的公牛。她经营公司的方式就是直接把所有人碾过去。还有她的钱。我真的很喜欢那些大丹犬。我是说真的。它们太棒了。
There was one scene where I said, let's have the Great Dane. We have to have one of them staring over my shoulder. Yes, I remember that. It's so brilliant. Yeah, the trainers walk around with a lot of baby diapers. The old-fashioned ones, because those dogs slobber a lot. Is it? So would they wipe them with the baby diaper?
有一场戏我说，让大丹犬上吧。我们必须让其中一只在我的肩膀后面盯着。是的，我记得。太精彩了。是的，驯犬师带着很多婴儿尿布到处走。那种老式的，因为那些狗会流很多口水。是吗？所以他们会用婴儿尿布擦吗？
Yeah, the baby, they keep their slobber there from coming out. And they were a mother and a son, actually. And I think they weighed about 120 pounds each. Just huge, but really sweet, you know, not really, you know, not really bright, but they were, you know, we had fun with them and I loved the scene where I was looking over my shoulders. So when that one looks over your shoulder, its head is bigger than yours. It's on camera is so big.
对，婴儿，他们用那个来防止口水流出来。其实它们是一对母子。我想它们每只大约有 120 磅重。体型巨大，但真的很温和，你知道，不是那种，你知道，不是特别聪明，但它们，你知道的，我们跟它们合作得很开心，我非常喜欢我从肩膀后面看过去的那场戏。所以当那只狗看着你的肩膀时，它的脑袋比你的还大。它在镜头里的存在感太强了。
Yeah, we kept trying to get him to bark. I don't know if we ever succeeded. is bigger than yours. It's like, its presence on camera is so big. Yeah, we kept trying to get him to bark. I don't know if we ever succeeded. I can't remember now. What was it like for you to be reunited with Rainn Wilson? He shared with us that you gave him his big break on Six Feet Under. You know what?
是的，我们一直试图让它叫。我不知道我们成功了没有。体型比你的还大。它在镜头里的存在感太强了。是的，我们一直试图让它叫。我不知道我们成功了没有。我现在记不清了。再次与雷恩·威尔逊合作是什么感觉？他跟我们分享说，是你给了他在《六尺之下》的大好机会。你知道吗？
He was so funny. I'll always have this memory. He came up. For some reason, we were shooting in Ruth's room and he had just been hired at the funeral home. And so he was rushing out the door. He had to do something. We gave him something to do. He had to go do it really quickly. And he ran out into the hallway and he took a right. And then there was this pause and he ran left because he realized that he didn't know where he was going because it was a completely new environment for him.
他太搞笑了。我永远会有这个记忆。他走过来。不知为什么，我们在露丝的房间里拍摄，他刚被殡仪馆雇佣。所以他正冲出门去。他得做点什么。我们给他安排了活。他得赶快去办。他跑到走廊里，向右拐了。然后停顿了一下，他又向左跑了，因为他意识到自己不知道要去哪儿，因为那对他来说是一个全新的环境。
And I thought, oh my God, this guy is brilliant. It was such an amazing choice. It was a shock. He was so wonderful to work with, so inventive, so funny. Well, all of the things that you saw working with him on the show, I'm sure. When I worked with him on your show, he had evolved quite a bit, you know, as an actor. And he's a very funny guy.
我当时想，天哪，这家伙太有才了。这是一个非常惊艳的选择。太震撼了。和他合作太棒了，非常有创造力，非常搞笑。嗯，所有你在剧中看他演出的那些特质，我相信都是真的。当我跟他在你的剧里合作时，他作为一个演员已经有了相当大的蜕变。他是个非常有趣的人。
Really, really liked working with him. Well, you know, we are both watching Matlock and we are loving it. I mean, everyone is loving it. Kathy, it is just taken off like wildfire and we would love to talk to you about it. Well, I'm happy to talk about it. Yeah, we're, we're the numbers are just crazy. They were just off the charts. And the best part about it is that everybody involved with it, whether it's the
真的，真的很喜欢和他合作。嗯，你知道，我们两个都在看《老练律师》，而且我们爱极了。我是说，所有人都在迷恋它。凯西，它简直像野火一样风靡开来，我们很想和你聊聊这个。嗯，我很高兴聊这个。是的，我们的，收视数字简直疯狂。简直直冲云霄。最棒的部分是，所有参与其中的人，无论是
president of the studio, Amy Reisenbach, who's been our big fan, and David Staff, the president of the studio and George Sheeks, who's kind of over all of us in Paramount. They're all so normal, you know, and they're accessible, they communicate and they send emails and you know, they came to our last table three, and I've never had that happen before. And then of course, there's Jenny Ehrman who created Jane the Virgin. And she's brilliant. Her mind works like a Rubik's Cube. And the layers that she's created in this series is just fascinating.
工作室总裁艾米·赖森巴赫，她一直是我们的超级粉丝，还有工作室总裁大卫·斯塔夫，以及在派拉蒙统筹全局的乔治·希克斯。他们都太正常了，你知道的，而且他们平易近人，善于沟通，会发邮件，你知道的，他们来了我们的最后一次读剧会，我以前从没遇到过这种事。当然还有创造了《处女情缘》的珍妮·埃尔曼。她太才华横溢了。她的思维就像一个魔方。她在本剧中创造的层次感简直令人着迷。
And I'm also an executive producer on the show. So they send me the episodes to take a look at, see if I have any suggestions. And I mean, it's just, I can't wait. I can't wait for what's coming up. So when I first met Jenny, you know, I first read the script and was, I was reading along. It seemed like it was just episodic, you know,
而且我还是这部剧的执行制片人。所以他们会把剧集发给我看，看看我有没有什么建议。我是说，这简直，我太期待了。我迫不及待地想看接下来的剧情了。所以当我第一次见到珍妮时，你知道，我第一次读剧本，一边读一边看。看起来似乎只是单元剧，你知道的，
that it was a case of the week. Yes. And then of course there's the twist at the end. And I was thrilled because I think, okay, now this is about substance. It's about something, it's about something meaningful. It's something I can really sink my teeth into. And I read it on a Friday. I met with her on a Monday and I said, don't change a word.
就是每周一个案件。是的。然后当然结尾有个反转。我当时激动极了，因为我想，太好了，现在这有深度了。这有内涵，这有意义。这是我能真正深入钻研的东西。我是周五读的。周一我和她见了面，我说，一个字都不要改。
I want to do this. And then we started talking about the character and where it was going and who she was, where she came from, all of the things, how she had planned to sell out with her grandson, you know, and it was fascinating. I just, I didn't, I've never imagined playing a character like this.
我想演这个。然后我们开始讨论这个角色以及它的走向、她是谁、她来自哪里、所有这些事情，她是如何计划带着孙子进行反击的，你知道，这太迷人了。我只是，我从未想象过自己能扮演这样一个角色。
Well, you're really playing two characters, right? So you're playing this sort of like, like explain that to people, because if you watch the first episode, if you watch the pilot, it's one of the best pilots of anything I've ever seen. I remember seeing the pilot for Breaking Bad and thinking, wow, that was a great pilot.
嗯，你其实是在扮演两个角色，对吧？所以你扮演的是这种，比如，能向大家解释一下吗，因为如果你看了第一集，如果你看了试播集，它是我看过最好的试播集之一。我记得我看《绝命毒师》的试播集时想，哇，那真是一个伟大的试播集。
And I felt the same way when I saw the pilot for Matlock. The twist at the end is genius, but you had me from the minute you stood at that coffee counter and you're bumbling, you get a guy to pay for your coffee, you're putting your, you get a guy to pay for your coffee. You get the candies in the packets. You're putting your candies in your hand and you trick your way in to this law firm,
当我看到《老练律师》的试播集时，我也有同感。结尾的反转是个天才之举，但从你站在咖啡柜台前的那一刻起你就吸引了我，你笨手笨脚的，让一个人帮你付咖啡钱，你把，你让一个人帮你付咖啡钱。你把包装袋里的糖果拿出来。你把糖果抓在手里，然后你用计谋混进了这家律所，
into their boardroom, into a job. It is amazing. I think so too. I mean, I had to keep asking Jenny questions about is this possible? I remember asking a friend of mine who's in corporate law, not corporate law, but he's in the corporate world. He's a dear friend of mine.
混进了他们的董事会，混进了一份工作。这太神奇了。我也这么觉得。我是说，我不得不一直问珍妮各种问题，这可能吗？我记得我问过一个做公司法的朋友，不是公司法，但他在企业界工作。他是我一个亲爱的朋友。
I said, could you do this? Could you do this? And he thought about it for a minute and he said, yeah, I could. And then I don't have kids, so I talked to my niece, she has a daughter who's now grown. And I said, but could and then I don't have kids so I talked to my niece She has a daughter who's now grown and I said but could you do this? Could you be this, you know? Devious and deceitful and lie to people all the time for your daughter and she said yes She said when you're a mother your love for your child is savage
我说，你能做到这一点吗？你能做到这一点吗？他想了一会儿说，是的，我能。而且我没有孩子，所以我跟我侄女聊过，她有一个已经长大的女儿。我说，但是你能做到吗？你能成为这样，你知道的，然后我没有孩子，所以我跟我侄女聊过，她有一个已经长大的女儿，我说，但是你能做到吗？你能成为这样的人吗？狡猾、欺骗，为了女儿一直对别人撒谎，她说，是的。她当母亲的时候，对孩子的爱是野性的，
and When you're a mother, your love for your child is savage. And I love, of course, the fact that she's older. I would never have believed that I could have done a series like this at my age, been asked to do one, and that we've gotten letters from people, from women who say, thank you, I don't feel invisible anymore. I think that you'll see as the series goes on that
当你成为母亲，你对孩子的爱是野性的。我当然很喜欢她年纪较大这一点。我以前绝不会相信自己在这个年纪能拍这样一部剧，会被邀请去演，而且我们收到了很多信件，来自女人们说，谢谢你，我不再觉得自己是隐形人了。我想随着剧集的推进，你会看到
Matlock is really falling in love with being a lawyer again. You know, she was in mourning for years and years and then her grandson saw this Reddit post and said that, you know, this is a way to get back at them. You know, she can plan everything she wants, but she doesn't expect to be a trial lawyer. And you find out later on in the third episode that she, you know, went into a contract law, because of a sexual abuse experience, instead of going into litigation, which is what she really wanted. And
马特洛克真的重新爱上了当律师的感觉。你知道的，她悲伤了整整好几年，然后她的孙子看到了这个 Reddit 的帖子，说，你知道的，这是回击他们的一种方式。你知道的，她可以计划她想做的一切，但她并没有指望自己能成为一名出庭律师。你在第三集中会发现，她因为一次性侵经历而转去了合同法领域，而不是她真正想进入的诉讼领域。而
I'm jumping all over here. but that was the seminal moment for her, that she was really able to make a difference, that she was able to remember her own sexual assault, and it changed her opinion about what young women go through nowadays. And it also shows not just the sexual assault, which is what we all talk about and how bad that is, and how prevalent that is. But it talks about what happens then? What happens after? Do you make a different career choice for women that are trying to get into show business and they get into a really bad situation? What happens to them after that? And in this case,
我这话说得有点跳跃。但那是对她而言最具决定性的时刻，她真正能够发挥作用，她能够回想起自己的性侵经历，这改变了她对如今年轻女性所经历的事情的看法。它不仅展现了性侵——这是我们都在谈论的、它有多糟糕以及它有多普遍——它还谈到了接下来会发生什么？之后会发生什么？对于那些试图进入演艺界却陷入极其糟糕境地的女性，她们会做出不同的职业选择吗？在那之后她们会怎么样？在这种情况下，
we see Maddie taking a divergent path, one that she wasn't happy with, and she didn't realize that until she met this young woman. So the fact that she's learning all of this from everyone is a very powerful thing to say in an episodic television show on network. I was going to say the idea, you know, I'm 53, but I'm still discovering things about myself and that life is a discovery. You don't age out of discovery. And I think sometimes we dismiss that we think that we can't discover new out of discovery. And I think sometimes we dismiss that. We think that we can't discover new things about ourselves. And I've really connected to that in this show.
我们看到麦蒂走了一条不同的道路，一条她并不开心的道路，直到她遇到这个年轻女性之前她都没有意识到这一点。因此，她从每个人身上学到所有这些东西，对于一部电视台播出的电视系列剧来说，是一个非常强有力的表达。我本来想说，你知道，我 53 岁了，但我仍在探索自我，生活是一场探索。你不会因为年龄增长而停止探索。而且有时我们认为自己不能探索，我们认为我们无法探索关于自我的新事物。我在剧中对这一点深有共鸣。
I agree. Yeah, I agree. That's a really good point. Every time I do something, I want to learn from it. And one of the most valuable things, as I was saying, being an seeing that happen in a show like this is so, I think that's one of the reasons people are so attracted to it. And it's people from all walks of life, which is what I really like. I feel so grateful that everyone on the show, I think that even the crew, there was a sense when we came back to do episode two, because it was the first time we'd shot in America, we shot the pilot in Toronto. So when we came back to do it here, there was just this buzz and this excitement about getting ready to do the show and the crew, you could feel it on the set. It was just, it was, it was new to me to feel that. And so, I mean, we would all go around looking at each other or even the day players
我同意。是的，我同意。这真的是个很好的观点。我每次做一件事，我都想从中学习。正如我所说，最有价值的事情之一，就是在这样一部剧中看到这一点发生，实在是，我认为这就是人们如此被它吸引的原因之一。而且吸引的是各行各业的人，这正是我非常喜欢的。我感到非常感激，剧组里的每个人，甚至包括剧组工作人员，当我们回来拍第二集时有一种感觉，因为我们在多伦多拍的试播集，所以当我们回到这里拍的时候，那种期待和兴奋感弥漫在片场，你能从剧组感受到。这对我来说是一种全新的体验。所以，我是说，我们都会环顾四周，甚至连临时演员
or the guest cast that would come in would just be looking at us going, oh my God, we can't believe it's like this. Is this, we've never worked on a show like this. So it's not just the material that we're putting out for everybody. It's also the experience of doing it every day and the joy of connecting and being vulnerable to one another so that the work really blossoms and you learn something about yourself.
或来客串的演员走进片场时都会看着我们说，天哪，我们不敢相信是这样的。这是，我们从来没有在这样的剧组工作过。所以这不仅仅是我们呈现给大家的素材。这也是每天工作的体验，以及那种建立连接、向彼此敞开心扉的快乐，这样作品才能真正绽放，你也能从中了解自己。
All I can say is I'm grateful. I'm just so grateful to have this experience. Well, the way you talk about it and the way your face lights up and the way you talk about the people and the crew and the experience, it just reminds me so much of working on The Office. Yes. Doesn't it, you? Angela? Yes, so much, especially Kathy, when you were talking about how exciting it is to get the scripts and have an input, you know, there was such a creative collaboration,
我只能说我很感激。我只是太感激能有这段经历了。嗯，你谈论它的方式，你脸上的光芒，你谈论人们、剧组和经历的方式，让我想起了在《办公室》工作的经历。是的。不是吗？你呢？安吉拉？是的，太像了，尤其是凯西，当你在谈论拿到剧本并能提出意见是多么令人兴奋时，你知道的，那是一种极具创造力的合作，
Greg Daniels set the tone for that, that we could go to the writers and we could pitch ideas to them. And that was so powerful and meaningful even as a supporting cast member. So I love that. And you see it in the work. You see the creative collaboration.
格雷格·丹尼尔斯为之定下了基调，我们可以去找编剧，向他们推销想法。即使作为一个配角，这也是非常有力量和意义的。所以我很喜欢这一点。而且你在作品中也能看到这一点。你能看到这种创造性的合作。
It's why we're hooked from the minute you're on screen. The cast is so fantastic. I really love the cast and we can't wait. You know, we'll keep talking about it. Well, I felt like for a minute I felt you were talking about the office. Oh, no, because it's the same way. I mean, you guys, you were full-blown people and there was, as you said before, you're living. That's what I'm always saying to Jenny, I don't want to play Maddie, I want to be Maddie. So that's what you guys were doing and the feeling on the set of The Office is, I thought you were talking about you guys, it's the same thing.
这就是为什么你一出场就把我们迷住了。演员阵容太棒了。我真的很喜欢演员阵容，我们等不及了。你知道的，我们会继续讨论它的。嗯，有一会儿我甚至觉得你在谈论《办公室》。哦，不，因为是一样的。我是说，你们大家，你们是完整鲜活的人，正如你之前所说，你们在生活。这就是我一直对珍妮说的，我不想扮演麦蒂，我想成为麦蒂。所以这就是你们当时在做的事情，《办公室》片场的感觉是，我以为你们在说你们自己呢，是一样的。
It is, it's the same thing. It is. It's the same thing. Well, you know, we also would love to talk to you about your advocacy work and your recent health journey. And I know Jenna had reached out to you and I would love to start that part of this conversation. Right. Jenna, can you tell me where you are in terms of your, I know I heard that you have breast cancer. Could you tell me a little bit about where you are in that journey? Sure. So I was diagnosed last December, December 2023. In January, I had a lumpectomy. And then I had a reconstructive surgery. I had a breast reduction and lift. And what they were able to do was take some of my own breast tissue and sort of fill in the hole where they removed the cancer. So I was,ed on the one side using my own tissue and then they made the other side match. And then I did 12 rounds of taxil chemotherapy.
是的，就是这样。是的。就是这样。嗯，你知道，我们也想和你聊聊你的公益倡导工作和最近的健康之旅。我知道珍娜曾联系过你，我很想开始对话的这一部分。好的。珍娜，你能告诉我你目前的状况吗，我知道我听说你得了乳腺癌。你能跟我聊聊你这段康复之旅的现状吗？当然。我是去年 12 月，即 2023 年 12 月被诊断出来的。1月，我做了肿瘤切除手术。然后我做了重建手术。我做了乳房缩小和提升手术。他们能够做的是取我自己的乳房组织，把切除癌症后留下的洞填补起来。所以我一边是用我自己的组织进行手术，然后他们让另一边对称。接着我做了 12 个疗程的紫杉醇化疗。
I got that once a week and I did three weeks of radiation and my breast cancer is triple positive, so it was positive for estrogen, progesterone and HER2. And so for a year, I received these immunotherapy infusions of a drug called Herceptin, which is a miracle drug that was discovered in my lifetime. Before this drug was introduced to the treatment plan for women with her two positive breast cancers, the survival rate was one of the lowest of the breast cancer diagnoses, and now it's one of the highest. And so I feel very blessed that this is part of my treatment plan.
我一周做一次，然后做了三周的放疗，我的乳腺癌是三阳性的，也就是说它对雌激素、孕激素和 HER2 呈阳性。所以在长达一年的时间里，我接受了名为曲妥珠单抗（Herceptin）的药物的免疫疗法输液，这是一种在我有生之年被发现的奇迹药物。在这种药物被引入 HER2 阳性乳腺癌女性的治疗方案之前，生存率是乳腺癌诊断中最低的之一，而现在它是最高的。所以我感到非常幸运，这是我治疗方案的一部分。
And so I've got a few more infusions of that ahead of me. I get those once every three weeks. And then I will be on tamoxifen, which is an estrogen blocker for five years. And that's my treatment plan. So I'm finished with the big three, as I called them, the surgery, the chemo and the radiation. And now I still have a few things ahead of me, but I'm riding waves of random side effects every day.
接下来我还有几次这种输液。我每三周做一次。然后我将服用他莫昔芬（一种雌激素阻断剂）五年。这就是我的治疗方案。所以我完成了我称之为“三大项”的治疗，即手术、化疗和放疗。现在我面前还有一些后续治疗，但我每天都在经历各种随机副作用的浪潮。
It's a little different. It's a little different, you know, it's, I know you, I don't know if you can relate, but one of the hardest parts of this whole process has been just the intense need for flexibility on a day-to-day basis, according to what my body can do, you know, and that's hard for me because I'm a real planner. I love a schedule. I love to do what I say I was going to do. And so that's kind of where I am in the process. Well, I had breast cancer, let's see, right, I think right as I started after I started working with you guys, it was 2012.
这有点不一样。这有点不同，你知道的，我知道你，我不知道你能不能感同身受，整个过程中最难的部分之一就是根据我的身体能承受的程度，对日常生活保持极高的灵活性，你知道的，这对我来说很难，因为我是一个十足的计划狂。我喜欢日程表。我喜欢按自己说要做的事去做。所以这基本上就是我目前的进度。嗯，我得乳腺癌的时候，让我想想，对，好像就在我开始和你们合作之后不久，那是 2012 年。
Right after. Yeah. And I had a very bad experience with it. I'd had a variant in 2003. And for some reason, even though I went through nine rounds of chemo for that, the chemo was really hard. I can't remember the names of the drugs, but I remember they gave me steroids and then I would be coming off the steroids and just getting, I don't know if you've gone through that, but that's been really difficult.
就在之后。是的。我在这方面的经历非常糟糕。我 2003 年得过卵巢癌。不知为什么，尽管我为此做了九个疗程的化疗，化疗真的非常难受。我不记得药物的名字了，但我记得他们给我用了类固醇，然后药效过後我就会开始，我不知道你有没有经历过，但那真的非常困难。
That was very difficult. I got steroids before each round of chemo, and I found that the steroids, the side effects of the steroids, having me be real amped and then crashing kind of right as the chemo would hit me, that was a rough couple days. Yeah. Yeah, that was what really, that was difficult for me. But with the breast cancer, that sort of came out of nowhere. I was speaking at Sloan Kettering about being a cancer survivor with ovarian cancer and then came home and discovered I had breast cancer,
那确实非常困难。我在每个化疗疗程前都会使用类固醇，我发现类固醇的副作用，让我整个人极度亢奋，然后在化疗开始见效时又急转直下，那几天简直太难熬了。对。是的，那真的，那对我很艰难。但乳腺癌那次，简直是毫无征兆。我在斯隆·凯特琳医院演讲，讲述自己作为卵巢癌幸存者的经历，然后回家就发现自己得了乳腺癌，
which was kind of ironic. And because it ran in my runs in my family, I said, you know, just take both off because I had, mainly it was in my left breast, but there were some troubling things in my right breast. And so I decided to have them both removed. I didn't opt for reconstruction. I don't know why.
这挺具有讽刺意味的。因为这有家族病史，我说，干脆两边都切掉吧，因为我主要是左侧乳房有问题，但右侧乳房也有一些让人不安的迹象。所以我决定把两边都切除。我没有选择重建。我不知道为什么。
I think at the time I just, I didn't wanna do it. And they put drains in and they're very thick, heavy, not heavy, but thick plastic drains. I'm familiar. I had the drains, yes. Yeah. And for some reason on the left side, it must have hit a nerve. I don't know what it was, but it was so painful. And I realized when they removed it, that's what the extra pain was.
我想当时我只是，我不想做。他们放了引流管，那是很粗、很重的，也不是重，但很粗的塑料引流管。我很熟悉。我也有过引流管，是的。是的，不知为什么在左侧，一定碰到了神经。我不知道是什么，但太痛了。当他们拔掉它时，我才意识到那就是额外疼痛的来源。
There was the pain involved. And then I developed lymphedema after that. My arms were very swollen. I could only wear men's shirts for a long time. And through my doctor here, I met Bill Rapisi, who is the CEO of the Lymphatic Education and Research Network. He asked me to come aboard as a national spokesperson. And I said, Bill, I've never done this before. I don't
有手术带来的疼痛。然后我之后患上了淋巴水肿。我的手臂肿得很厉害。很长一段时间我只能穿男式衬衫。通过我这里的医生，我认识了比尔·拉皮西，他是淋巴教育与研究网络的首席执行官。他邀请我加入担任全国代言人，我说，比尔，我以前从未做过这个。我
know if I can do a good job, what's involved. But he told me a couple of really disturbing facts that nearly 10 million people in this country suffer from some kind of lymphedema, and about 50,000 of those are congenital. So it strikes kids. When we were lobbying in Congress, I met a man who lost three kids to pulmonary lymphedema. Doctors in medical school, in four years of medical school, spend 15 minutes on learning about the lymphatic system. And see, Kathy, I did not know what lymphedema was and when you started talking about it is when I learned about it. And Jenna had shared with me as well. So I think this is so important to talk about. Yeah, something like 20% of breast cancer patients develop lymphedema. And it's because when you get your breast cancer surgery,
不知道自己能不能做好，这其中涉及什么。但他告诉我一些非常令人不安的事实，这个国家有近 1000 万人患有某种淋巴水肿，其中大约 5 万人是先天的。所以它会袭击儿童。我们在国会游说时，我遇到了一位因肺淋巴水肿失去三个孩子的父亲。医学院的医生在四年的医学院学习中，只花 15 分钟来了解淋巴系统。你看，凯西，我以前不知道什么是淋巴水肿，直到你开始谈论它我才了解到。珍娜也跟我分享过。所以我觉得谈论这个太重要了。是的，大约 20% 的乳腺癌患者会发展成淋巴水肿。这是因为当你做乳腺癌手术时，
something that is just standard, is they remove some of your lymph nodes to test them for cancer to see if the cancer has spread. That from the breast, those lymph nodes underneath your arm, that's first stop shopping for the cancer, so they test those lymph nodes but they remove them And when you mess with the lymphatic system like that, when you do that surgery, you increase your risk of developing lymphedema. And it was something that luckily my doctor did explain to me before my surgery.
一个标准程序就是切除你的一些淋巴结来检测癌症，看看癌症是否已经扩散。从乳房扩散出来的那些你胳膊底下的淋巴结，那是癌症的第一站，所以他们会检测那些淋巴结，但他们会把它们切除。当你这样干预淋巴系统，当你做那次手术时，你患淋巴水肿的风险就增加了。幸运的是，在我的手术前，我的医生确实向我解释了这一点。
They educated me on the warning signs about my arms swelling or my legs or ankles swelling. And my cancer was on my left side and I had my lymph nodes removed on my left side. And they have told me that whenever I get a blood pressure cuff, it needs to be on my right side. And if I'm going to get an IV, it needs to be placed on my right side, because that is just how incredibly vulnerable your lymphatic system is to disturbance. Well, I'm thrilled to hear you say all a top notch place here, but the doctors didn't talk to me about that. I kept talking to them about it, because I had been dating a guy at the time who had it in his
他们向我普及了手臂肿胀或腿部、脚踝肿胀的警告信号。我的癌症在左侧，我左侧的淋巴结也被切除了。他们告诉我，无论什么时候量血压，血压袖带都必须戴在右手臂上。如果我要输液，也必须打在右手臂上，因为你的淋巴系统对干扰是多么的脆弱。听到你这么说我太震惊了，这里虽然是个顶级的地方，但医生们根本没跟我谈过这个。我一直在跟他们谈这个，因为当时我正在和一个胳膊有这个病的男友交往，
left arm, and it's progressive, and it's incurable. And he had gone through through experimental treatment to survive cancer and did not wanna go to another doctor until ever in his life. And as a result, his arm became like wood. Oh my gosh. And that was my fear. And also that I was afraid that that was what lymphedema was.
而且它是进行性的，是不治之症。他为了战胜癌症经历过实验性治疗，这辈子再也不想去看医生了。结果，他的手臂变得像木头一样。哦天哪。那正是我的恐惧。我也害怕那正是淋巴水肿。
And I was full of rage because I had told the doctors, I'm worried about this, I'm worried about this, I'm worried about this. And they took so many lymph nodes. But I'm thrilled that they told you all of that. Because back then, my doctor had to go and look it up on the internet. Wow. Yeah, he found this woman, wonderful Dr. Emily Eicher, who was able to work with me and get my arms down over a period of time. And now that I've lost a lot of weight, that really helped. But trying to educate people over the last 10 years has been a real journey. We would get emails from people. I remember one guy, I'll never forget him, John Dale, who wrote us an email and at the end of the email, all capital letters, help me, help me, help me, help me, help me, because the people are in so
我当时充满了愤怒，因为我曾对医生说：“我担心这个，我担心这个，我担心这个。”他们切除了那么多的淋巴结。但我很高兴他们把这些都告诉你了。因为当年，我的医生不得不去互联网上查资料。哇。是的，他找到了这位女士，了不起的埃米·艾歇尔博士，她能够与我合作，并在一段时间内让我的手臂消肿了。现在我减了很多肥，那真的很有帮助。但在过去的 10 年里，试图教育人们一直是一段真正的旅程。我们会收到人们的电子邮件。我记得有一个人，我永远不会忘记他，约翰·代尔，他给我们发了一封电子邮件，在邮件的最后，全是大写字母：“救救我，救救我，救救我，救救我，救救我”，因为人们处于极度痛苦中
much pain, they don't know who to go to. I'm really proud of all the work that we've done with learn our CEO has gone all around the world. We have now the first national commission on lymphatic disease at the NIH. They had their first meeting a couple of months ago and we worked really hard to have that happen. Rosa DeLauro of Connecticut,
，他们不知道该去找谁。我真的为我们通过 learn 开展的所有工作感到自豪，我们的首席执行官走遍了世界各地。我们现在在 NIH（美国国立卫生研究院）有了第一个国家淋巴疾病委员会。他们几个月前开了第一次会议，我们为实现这一目标付出了巨大的努力。来自康涅狄格州的罗莎·德劳罗，
the congresswoman there was instrumental in getting us the attention that we needed to get this commission going. We got a grant from the CDC for publicity to really create our outreach for people. We're not working on the DOD because it's not just underneath our arms. If these veterans come back and their traumatic injuries have damaged their, uh, lymph system. They're at risk. We have a man who wanted to be in the coast guard and he came back from
那里的女国会议员在为我们争取成立这个委员会所需的关注方面发挥了关键作用。我们从疾控中心获得了一笔用于宣传的拨款，以真正建立我们对外沟通的渠道。我们现在正在努力争取国防部（的关注），因为这不仅仅发生在胳膊底下。如果这些退伍军人归来，他们的创伤性损伤破坏了他们的淋巴系统，他们也会面临风险。我们有一个人曾想加入海岸警卫队，他从
military and he was just a mess. And he had to give up that dream. That's been the most moving and sad parts of this is realizing that people had to give up their greens because of, of, and there's a kind of lymphedema that happens when you're like late teens, early twenties, when you're just beginning your life and out of nowhere, they don't know what it is. It's some predisposition that occurs at that time. And I appreciate so much you're letting me talk about it on your show, because education is key. And I always tell the people that they're at our lobby sessions in Washington, DC,
军队退役回来后，情况一团糟。他不得不放弃那个梦想。这是其中最感人和最悲伤的部分，意识到人们不得不因为这个而放弃自己的梦想，而且有一种淋巴水肿发生在十几岁晚期、二十岁出头的时候，当你正开始生活时，它就无缘无故地出现了，他们也不知道那是什么。那是当时发生的某种易感性。我非常感谢你让我能在你的节目中谈论这个，因为教育是关键。我总是对那些参加我们在华盛顿特区游说会议的人说，
your pain is your power. Your story is your power. And the fact that you can share your story with me, and you can tell people how far we've come. Yeah. It's amazing that you have perky breasts. Yeah. You know.
你的痛苦就是你的力量。你的故事就是你的力量。你能把你的故事分享给我，并且告诉大家我们已经走到了这一步。是的。你还能有挺拔的乳房，这太神奇了。是的。你知道的。
I do like how my shirts fit me better now. I'll say that. And my hair, Kathy, after chemotherapy, so before the chemotherapy, my hair was almost all gray. And after chemotherapy, my hair is growing in not gray. Oh my God. So I heard that people said,
我确实挺喜欢我的衬衫现在穿起来更合身了。我得这么说。还有我的头发，凯西，化疗之后，化疗前，我的头发几乎全白了。而化疗后，我长出来的头发不再是白色的了。天哪。所以我听说别人说，
oh, if you have straight hair, it might come back curly. If you have curly hair, like it'll come back a different texture. It might come back a different color. And you're not having to color your hair. No, how about that? That's so great. I'm jelly. I'm not having to color your hair. How about that? That's so great. I'm jelly. I'm totally jelly. No, I lost everything. I lost every hair everywhere. Some of it I'm glad I lost. But it took me a while to get it back. Yeah, it was
哦，如果你是直发，它可能会变成卷发。如果你是卷发，它可能会变成不同的质地。它可能会变成不同的颜色。而你不需要给头发染色。不，怎么样？太棒了。我太嫉妒了。我不需要给头发染色。怎么样？太棒了。我太嫉妒了。我完全嫉妒。不，我什么都没了。我身上所有的头发都没了。有些没了倒让我挺高兴的。但这花了我一段时间才长回来。是的，这很
hard. They don't you know, they when I heard that I was gonna have to have chemo. My first two thoughts were I don't want to throw up and I don't want to lose, they, when I heard that I was going to have to have chemo, my first two thoughts were I don't want to throw up and I don't want to lose my hair. That's what I associated chemotherapy with. And, um, I didn't throw up, but I did lose my hair and I, it didn't occur to me until it was happening
难。它们不，你知道的，当我听说我必须做化疗时，我的前两个想法是，我不想呕吐，我不想失去，它们，当我听说我必须做化疗时，我的前两个想法是，我不想呕吐，我不想失去头发。这就是我对化疗的联想。而且，我没有呕吐，但我确实失去了头发，直到事情发生我才意识到
that it is all your hair. It's your eyebrows and your eyelashes and all of it everywhere. And it's weird. My eyebrows came back real quickly though. I was happy for that because I was not great at drawing them in. But it's really weird to not have eyelashes. You know?
那是你所有的头发。那是你的眉毛、睫毛，还有全身各处所有的毛发。这感觉很奇怪。不过我的眉毛长得挺快的。我为此很高兴，因为我不太擅长画眉毛。但没有睫毛感觉真的很奇怪。你知道吗？
Yeah, I don't think my eyelashes really came back or maybe it just being older. Yeah, I had a friend my eyelashes really came back. Or maybe it's just being older. Yeah, I had a friend of mine actually, Judy Corey, who did my hair for Misery, she came and that was back in 2003. She came over and shaved my head for me. And then after I had a bald head, I mean, I did use all these, I had things made
是的，我觉得我的睫毛没有真正长回来，或者可能只是因为年纪大了。是的，我有一个朋友，我的睫毛真的长回来啦。或者可能只是因为年纪大了。是的，我有一个朋友，朱迪·科里，她曾为《危情十日》给我做过发型，她过来了，那是 2003 年的事。她过来帮我剃了光头。然后在我顶着光头之后，我是说，我确实用了所有这些，我让人制作了
like caps and all this bulls**t wigs and everything. And finally I just thought, I saw Melissa Etheridge, you know, just wailing on her guitar on some kind of a show with the bald head and I thought, oh, okay, you know, time to just stop all this hiding and just be who you are. But I'm thrilled that there are all of these new, what was the H one that you said? Oh yeah, Herceptin. Yeah, it's a targeted immunotherapy. I mean really it's only been out for about 25 years and it has just drastically changed the
像帽子、所有这些鬼扯的假发以及各种东西。最后我只是想，我看到梅丽莎·埃瑟里奇，你知道的，在某个节目里顶着光头疯狂弹着吉他，我想，哦，好吧，你知道，是时候停止所有这些躲藏，做回你自己了。但我很高兴有所有这些新的，你刚才说那个 H 开头的药是什么？哦，对，曲妥珠单抗。对，这是一种靶向免疫疗法。我是说，它真的只问世了大约 25 年，它彻底改变了
prognosis for women with HER2 positive breast cancers. Wow. It's really amazing. Wow. Oh bless you. You didn't have to go through that. And you're not having any problems with your arm. I am not. No. And I'm really, I'm really grateful for that. And, and after my surgery, my doctor also prescribed some physical therapy. So I was able to get that side moving. It's very tender though. I have to say of all my scars, of all of the ways that I've been poked and prodded
HER2 阳性乳腺癌女性的预后。哇。真是太神奇了。哇。哦，真为你高兴。你不用经历那些。而且你的胳膊没有任何问题。我没有。没有。我真的非常感激这一点。而且，手术后，我的医生还开了一些物理治疗。所以我得以让那一侧活动起来。不过真的很痛。我得说，在我所有的伤口中，在我为了安装输液港以及所有这一切经历过的各种穿刺和折腾中，
in this process of getting a port and all the things, that scar underneath my arm from where they removed the lymph nodes is the most tender. It's still tight when I try to raise my arm above my head. It is really truly such a sensitive area. Yeah, it's gonna be tender I think. I mean, this is new. You've only had it for a year gone through it.
切除淋巴结的那个胳膊底下的伤口是最痛的。当我试图把手臂举过头顶时，它依然很紧绷。那真的是一个非常敏感的区域。是的，我想它会一直很痛。我是说，这还很新。你才经历了一年。
Yeah, January is the anniversary of my surgery. Look at all you've done in a year. I know. Well, you know, Kathy, I remember you worked right after your chemotherapy. You went back to work pretty quickly. And I read something that you said, which was that it was a little bit of an opportunity to be not a cancer patient. You got to play a character. And I have kept working through my treatment
对，一月就是我手术的周年纪念日。看看你这一年里做了多少事。我知道。嗯，你知道，凯西，我记得你在化疗刚结束就工作了。你很快就回去工作了。我读过你说过的一句话，那就是这稍微算是一个机会，可以不用当一个癌症患者。你可以去扮演一个角色。我也一直在治疗期间坚持工作，
and I needed that for my mental health. I needed a place that I went throughout the week. And I just laughed with my best friend. And we talked about these great memories of our time on this show together. Because really, truly, it is so many appointments. It is so much of my life and my time is spent with doctors and being a patient that I needed a place where I wasn't that.
我需要这个来维持我的心理健康。我需要一个在一周里可以去的地方。我和我最好的朋友一起大笑。我们谈论了我们在剧中一起度过的美好回忆。因为真的，坦白说，有太多的预约了。我的生活和时间有很大一部分都是和医生在一起度过的，作为一个病人，我需要一个我不是病人的地方。
Yeah, that's true. Lynn Redgrave, God rest her, she was going through fifth stage breast cancer and on the downward slope. I wasn't done with chemo there actually, I just was about to start it. And I was having gastro problems. And she said, you got to do this, can be somebody else, you know, as you're saying for the day. And she was right. You know, it gave me a lot of pretty cranky for a while, because I just wasn't I wasn't healed yet. Yeah, know, I was, it was a little too soon, but it was also, I couldn't turn down the payday. I really needed the payday because I really dropped out. I was scared.
是的，真的是这样。琳娜·雷德格雷夫，愿她安息，她当时正经历第五期乳腺癌，而且处于走下坡路的阶段。其实我当时还没做完化疗，我只是刚准备开始。而且我当时有肠胃问题。她说，你必须这样做，可以暂时成为别人，正如你刚才所说的那样。她是正确的。你知道的，它让我有一段时间变得相当暴躁，因为我只是，我还没痊愈。是的，你知道，我当时，确实有点太早了，但这也是因为我不能拒绝片酬。我真的很需要这笔片酬，因为我真的跌入谷底了。我很害怕。
I was one of those people, and this was with the ovarian. I was one of those people who stayed up at night, you know, and looked at the internet to see if I could divine anything. But knock wood, it's been 20 years and I don't think I'm going to be having more problems with that. How are you doing emotionally? Oh, you're so kind to ask. How am I doing emotionally? I'm okay most of the time, but at least once a week I get mad because every day I feel like I have to swim upstream a little bit. I have to swim against the current just to have a normal day. And it's exhausting.
我是那种人，而且这是在卵巢癌时期。我是那种深夜不睡觉，在网上查阅看看能不能占卜出什么结果的人。但谢天谢地，已经 20 年过去了，我觉得我不会再有这方面的问题了。你现在情绪怎么样？哦，你太贴心了，居然问这个。我情绪怎么样？大部分时间我还行，但至少一周有一次我会生气，因为我觉得每天我都得逆流而上一点点。我必须逆着潮流游泳才能度过一个正常的一天。这太累人了。
But I am really so very well supported by my husband and by friends, by Angela. But I did notice that there was a real swell of support during chemotherapy, that there was a real swell of support during chemotherapy. I think because people know how hard that is to get through. And when the chemo was over, some of the support went away. Sometimes I feel like I'm bothering people or I feel like they're gonna get frustrated with me. They're gonna be like, geez, is this ever gonna end with her? And that's how I feel.
但我真的得到了我丈夫、朋友们以及安吉拉非常好的支持。不过我确实注意到，在化疗期间确实有一波真正的支持浪潮，在化疗期间确实有一波真正的支持浪潮。我想是因为人们知道熬过那个过程有多难。当化疗结束时，一部分支持就消失了。有时我觉得我在打扰别人，或者我觉得他们会对我不耐烦。他们会觉得，天哪，她这什么时候才是个头啊？这就是我的感受。
I feel like, geez, is this ever gonna end with me? But I do still need support. And I think that's something I would want people to know if they have a friend or a family member going through this, is that the struggle doesn't end when the treatments quote unquote end, you know? I think that's a great point. And I think that's exactly what I experienced when I had ovarian cancer.
我觉得，天哪，这在我身上什么时候才是个头啊？但我确实仍然需要支持。我想如果有人有朋友或家人正在经历这一切，我希望他们能明白这一点，那就是当治疗“所谓”结束时，挣扎并没有真正结束，你知道的？我觉得这是一个很好的观点。我想这正是我得卵巢癌时的亲身经历。
You know, I had a friend at the time who was so supportive. And I remember at one point, we were getting ready to go somewhere and I was sitting on a step, lacing my shoes and my cap fell off and he sort of laughed. And I just said, this is so hard for me. And then I found out that as I progressed through the chemotherapy, this was for ovarian,
你知道，当时我有个朋友非常支持我。我记得有一次，我们正准备出门，我坐在台阶上系鞋带，帽子掉了下来，他笑了笑。我当时就说，这对我来说太难了。后来我发现，随着我的化疗进展——我得的是卵巢癌，
that people have exactly that reaction only they left sooner because it went on for nine months. My doctor wanted me to do it for six months, but he said, you're doing well, so let's do it, you know, another three months. And people just sort of dropped away because they didn't, they said, wow, you know, isn't this over? Isn't it going to be done? Is it, you know, they didn't have the patients really. And so I went to my chemotherapy sessions by myself. I got to the point. Oh, Cathy.
人们确实会有这种反应，只是他们因为疗程持续了九个月而更早地离开了。我的医生本想让我做六个月，但他说，你恢复得不错，所以我们再做三个月吧。大家就那样渐渐疏远了，因为他们觉得，哇，这还没结束吗？还没弄完吗？他们其实没有这个耐心。所以我都是自己一个人去化疗的。我甚至到了……哦，凯茜。
Well, I got to the point of where I would just go by myself. It was easier to go and hope that I got the really good looking Russian nurse who would come in. I don't know what his name was. I can't remember. Vasily or something like that or Yvonne or what. I was like, oh my God, he's here today. Great, great. But it would take about four hours to be in there. And they gave me a private room and all of that. So being a VIP help. And thank God with the breast cancer, I didn't have to go through chemotherapy or radiation, which is one reason why I opted to just make it a double.
嗯，我后来习惯一个人去了。这样更省事，还能碰碰运气，希望遇到那个长得很帅的俄罗斯护士来给我治疗。我不知道他叫什么名字。记不清了。瓦西里之类的，或者伊万什么的。我当时想，哦天哪，他今天在。太好了，太好了。不过每次要在里面待大约四个小时。他们给我安排了独立病房之类的。所以VIP身份还是有帮助的。谢天谢地，得了乳腺癌后，我不用经历化疗或放疗，这也是我选择直接做双侧切除的原因之一。
But I was really enraged after, but we talked about that before. And it wasn't until I sat with Dr. Eicher, and I told her all of the things I was feeling and the rage that I was feeling. And she's this charming little woman, Czechoslovakian. And she's just said something like, okay, well, let's have a glass of champagne. And then we would begin the rest of your life.
但我当时其实非常愤怒，不过我们之前聊过这个。直到我坐在艾彻医生的诊室里，把我的各种感受和内心的愤怒都倾诉给她。她是个迷人的捷克斯洛伐克小个子女人。她只是说了句类似这样的话：好吧，那我们喝杯香槟吧。然后我们再开启你余下的人生。
Somehow she just slowly pulled me out of my rage and then working with with learn I was able to use it. You know to to give it purpose to give it purpose to give back to do something real in the real world which is like what you guys are doing. Angela have you ever had to deal with anything like this. Yes my grandmother and my aunt were all breast cancer survivors. My grandmother passed away but not from cancer. And my aunt, my mom's sister, had a really rough go. But she's doing much better now. So I go and get my mammograms and try to stay on top of it.
不知怎么的，她就这样慢慢把我从愤怒中拉了出来。后来通过与“学”组织的合作，我能够利用这段经历。你知道的，赋予它意义，赋予它目标，去回馈社会，在现实世界中做一些真正的事，就像你们正在做的那样。安吉拉，你曾经经历过类似的事情吗？是的，我的外祖母和阿姨都是乳腺癌幸存者。我外祖母去世了，但不是因为癌症。我阿姨，也就是我妈妈的妹妹，经历了一段非常艰难的时期。但她现在好多了。所以我都会去定期做乳房X光检查，时刻关注自己的健康。
But when Jenna got her diagnosis, all I wanted to do was be a source of support. And I wanted to just be strong for her. And, you know, we never really talked it out about just the scary side of it and those emotions until we sat down on our podcast to talk about it for the first time. I think I cried for 20 minutes and we couldn't even use it because it was the first time I said out loud, she's cancer-free. We finally talked about it. I completely fell apart. I held it together for a year, but then I just fell apart because just watching someone you care about go through it and not knowing what the hell you can do other than to just say, I'm thinking of you and I love you and I'm praying for you. And that's about it.
但当珍娜确诊时，我只想成为她坚实的后盾。我只想在她面前表现得坚强。而且，你知道的，直到我们坐到播客节目里第一次公开谈论这件事之前，我们从未真正敞开心扉聊过那些可怕的一面和种种情绪。我想我当时哭了20分钟，那些内容甚至都播不了，因为那是我第一次亲口说出：她已经战胜癌症了。我们终于谈起了这件事。我彻底崩溃了。我强撑了一整年，但在那一刻我还是崩溃了，因为看着你在乎的人经历这一切，除了对她说“我想你、我爱你、我为你祈祷”之外，却完全不知道自己究竟能做些什么。差不多也就这些了。
And just try to keep being there for her and being steadfast and hoping I was enough to help her when she needed it. But it is so important that you guys are sharing about it. It's so important. We've had so many people reach out to us when Jenna shared and Kathy, I know you're having this experience too, that the burden of feeling alone in it, the burden of feeling like you can't talk about it,
只能试着继续陪伴在她身边，坚定不移地支持她，希望我的存在能在她需要时给予她足够的力量。但你们能把这些分享出来真的太重要了。太重要了。当珍娜分享了她的经历后，有那么多人都联系了我们，凯茜，我知道你也有同感，那种在痛苦中感到孤立无援的重担，那种觉得无法向人倾诉的煎熬，
that itself is just too much to bear, I think, on top of everything else. And I'm so happy to be part of this conversation with you all and for people listening to hear it. Oh, thank you. Too many of us, and younger and younger and younger, are getting breast cancer, developing breast cancer, developing breast cancer. And I'm so heartened by what I've learned from you today, Jenna, because to realize that the strides that they've made just in the last 20 years is phenomenal.
我觉得，比起其他所有事情来，光是这一点就已经让人难以承受了。我很高兴能参与你们的这次对话，也很高兴听到大家能听到这些。哦，谢谢。我们当中有太多人，而且越来越年轻，正在患上乳腺癌，罹患乳腺癌，罹患乳腺癌。珍娜，今天从你这里了解到的这一切让我深受鼓舞，因为我意识到他们仅仅在过去20年里取得的进步简直是惊人的。
And I wish I'd had that kind of pre-vamp. I'm trying to remember the name of the chemo that I was on for ovarian. Did you get it every three weeks? Yeah. Yeah. I got one that was once a week. Do you recall the name of it?
我也希望我当时能有那种提前准备。我努力回想我当时做卵巢癌化疗用的是什么药。你当时是每三周做一次吗？对。对。我用的是一周一次的那种。你还记得它的名字吗？
Mine was called Taxol. You know, I think that's the same one I had, but only every three weeks. Oh yeah, they can do it in other doses. Yeah, they can do it, yeah. Did you know that it comes from the yew tree and the druids felt that the U tree was represented rebirth? No, but can I tell you something? So every time they brought, I'm going to get emotional, every time they brought the chemotherapy in to the room and every time they
我的那款叫紫杉醇。你知道，我觉得我和你用的是同一种，只不过我是每三周一次。哦，对，他们可以采用不同的剂量。对，可以的，对。你知道它提取自红豆杉吗？德鲁伊特觉得红豆杉代表着新生。不知道，不过我能告诉你一件事吗？所以每次他们把——我要情绪激动了——每次他们把化疗药物推病房里，每次他们
bring the Herceptin in. My husband would go up to it and he would thank it for being there. He would say, thank you. We welcome you into Jenna's body to do your work. You are welcome here. We are so excited to have you here. We are happy you exist.
把赫赛汀推进来。我丈夫都会走到药瓶旁，感谢它的到来。他会说，谢谢你。欢迎你进入珍娜的身体去发挥作用。这里欢迎你。很高兴你能来到这里。我们很高兴你的存在。
And we welcome you into her body to rid her of this cancer. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. My husband said, he said, if when it gets in the room, we tense up and we hate it and we're negative. He said that it's just he was like, I want us to have a different attitude when it comes in the room. I want us to have an attitude of gratitude. I want us to thank it for being here. And he said, I think that that will, that openness in your body to accept this medicine will help it do its work. That's what he said. Isn't that beautiful?
我们欢迎你进入她的身体，帮她清除体内的癌症。天哪。天哪。我丈夫说，他说，如果当药物推进病房时，我们感到紧张、厌恶而且充满负面情绪。他说，这只会——他觉得，我希望当它进到病房时，我们能抱有不同的态度。我希望我们怀着一颗感恩的心。我希望感谢它的到来。他说，我认为这种敞开身体去接纳药物的态度，会帮助它更好地发挥作用。他是这么说的。是不是很美好？
That's phenomenal. That's phenomenal. And I think it's right. Yeah. Yeah. And I can't believe what you said about that tree. Oh, yes, my niece dug that up. Wow. You know, I was an old hippie at one point in my life. So yeah. Well, Kathy, thank you for sharing all of that. Yes, thank you. First of all, we are going to share everything about the Lymphatic Education and Research Network on our social media. I will put swipe-ups to links so people can learn more. And then we thought we would end this interview with a tradition from the office call sheets.
这太惊人了。太惊人了。而且我觉得他说得对。对。对。而且我真不敢相信你刚才说的那种树。哦，对，我侄女挖出过这个。哇。你知道的，我曾经是个老嬉皮士。所以，是的。好吧，凯茜，谢谢你分享这一切。对，谢谢。首先，我们会在我们的社交媒体上分享关于淋巴教育与研究网络的一切。我会附上链接的上滑跳转，以便大家了解更多。然后我们想用办公室通告单上的一个传统来结束这次采访。
On the back of our call sheets, they would do a few questions and get to know the cast and crew. And they would do a few questions and get to know the cast and crew and they would feature a new person each week. So Jenna and I picked our three favorite questions that were the regular questions and we'd like to ask them to you. Okay. The first one is what is a place that you have been to that you absolutely loved? I was at a place called the Spring Cottage. It was in England. It was on the Thames. It belonged to Lady Astor.
在我们通告单的背面，通常会有几个问题，用来让大家了解演员和剧组。通告单上会设置几个问题来帮助大家了解演员和剧组人员，并且每周都会介绍一个新面孔。所以珍娜和我挑选了我们最喜欢的三个常规问题，想向你提问。好的。第一个问题是：你去过的哪个地方是你绝对挚爱的？我曾经去过一个叫“泉水小屋”的地方。它在英国，泰晤士报河畔。它曾属于阿斯特夫人。
It's now part of the National Preserve there. And we were doing a movie and I got to stay down at the Spring Cottage and it was right on the river and it had its own boat. It had a butler, if you can believe that. And it's where Lady Sutherland lived and Queen Victoria would come and have tea there. And you can look at pictures of it. It's just so beautiful. Clifton House, Taplow, yeah, built for Queen Victoria by the Sutherlands. And it's located on the River Thames in the
它现在是当地国家自然保护区的一部分。当时我们在拍一部电影，我得以住在泉水小屋里，它就紧邻着河边，还有它自己的小船。甚至还有一个管家，你敢相信吗。萨瑟兰夫人曾住在那里，维多利亚女王也曾去那里喝过茶。你可以看看它的照片。真的是美极了。克利夫顿庄园，塔普洛，是的，那是萨瑟兰家族为维多利亚女王建造的。它位于泰晤士河畔的
grounds of Clibdon House. It's a three-bedroom, riverside property with a private garden and covered porch. Well, that sounds lovely. I mean, done, okay. But Kathy, you've also like traveled the country in an RV, right? Yes, I did.
克利夫顿庄园领地上。这是一栋带有私人花园和带顶门廊的三卧河畔房产。听起来真不错。好吧，就这样，行。不过凯茜，你也曾开着房车在全国各地旅行过，对吧？是的，我去过。
Kathy. Or I recently sold it, but I loved it. This is one of my favorite memories of being in Hair and makeup with you is that I was wanting to go on a road trip and you were telling me about your RV trips in hair and makeup. And that was a dream of my dad's.
凯茜。或者我最近把它卖了，但我真的很喜欢它。我在化妆间和你在一起时最美好的回忆之一，就是当时我正想去自驾游，而你在化妆间跟我讲了你开房车旅行的经历。那是我爸爸的一个梦想。
And I just loved it. I hung on your every word. I was like, I wanna load up and go see America. It's great. When I bought it, my niece said at the time it's the boomer thing to do, but we found these wonderful places to stay and a lot of them, I guess it is a boomer thing to do. You can find these beautiful places with your pads that you have all of your electricity.
我简直爱极了。我把你的每一句话都听进去了。我当时就想，我也要装满行囊去看看美国。这太棒了。当我买下它的时候，我侄女当时说，这是嬉皮士老一辈（婴儿潮一代）才会做的事，但我们找到了这些绝佳的露营地，其中很多地方——我想这确实是婴儿潮一代的爱好吧。你可以找到这些风景优美的地方，那里有配齐所有电力设施的营位。
You have like a barbecue place, but then don't have a main building where you can do laundry. you know, a barbecue place, but they don't have a main building where you can do laundry. And there's, I mean, some of them are just out of this world. I highly recommend them, especially if you have a loved one. It's really a couple's thing to do. Yeah. Or a family thing to do. I'm curious, what was your favorite spot that you visited in your RV? Or what, did you go to a lot of national parks and things?
你有一个烧烤的地方，但却没有一个可以洗衣服的主楼。你知道，有一个烧烤的地方，但他们没有可以洗衣服的主楼。而且——我是说，其中有些地方简直美得不可思议。我强烈推荐，特别是如果你有伴侣相伴。这真的很适合情侣一起去。对，或者适合全家人一起去。我很想知道，你在房车旅行中访问过最喜欢的地点是哪里？或者说，你去过很多国家公园之类的地方吗？
Actually, my favorite place, I went to my hometown, Memphis, and through friends, I found a very simple spot on the western side of the Mississippi. And we were right there with the Mississippi River. Literally, there was nothing in between us. And his family had left it to him, this piece of property, and he turned it into an RV park. I don't know what it is now.
其实，我最喜欢的地方，是我回到了我的家乡孟菲斯，通过朋友的介绍，我在密西西比河西岸找到了一处非常朴素的营地。我们就挨着密西西比河。真的，我们和河之间没有任何遮挡。这块地产是他家人留给他的，他把它改造成了一个房车公园。我现在也不知道它变成什么样了。
That was one of my favorite places. Two of your favorite places are on a river, Kathy. Yeah, I like rivers. Our next question is, do you play a musical instrument? I used to play the guitar and I don't anymore. But I have a couple of ones that I really, really enjoy. And the first job I ever got was a movie called Taking Off. And I had, I played a song that I wrote when I was 16. And it was in the movie. It was Milo Shormann's first film, American film. But that's been many, many years ago. I loved playing. I taught myself
那是我的最爱之一。你最喜欢的两个地方都在河边，凯茜。对，我喜欢河流。我们的下一个问题是：你会演奏乐器吗？我以前弹过吉他，但现在不弹了。不过我有几件真的很喜欢、很享受的乐器。我接到的第一份工作是一部叫《脱衣舞娘》（Taking Off）的电影。我弹了一首我16岁时写歌。它被收录进电影里了。那是米洛斯·福尔曼的第一部电影，美国电影。但那是很多很多年以前的事了。我曾经很喜欢弹奏。我自学了
how to play. And so it was, I miss it. Wow. Okay. That is so cool. I mean, you wrote a song that's in a movie. That's just It's amazing. That's pretty cool Last question. What do you like to do on the weekends? Ah It depends What I like to do on the weekends sometimes I like to go to a real movie theater and see a movie like to do on the weekends. Sometimes I like to go to a real movie theater and see a movie. Sometimes I'm learning lines, it's depending if I'm working or not. What else do I like to do? I like to color. I like to color coloring books and stuff. And I have, in fact, Jenny Erman, who
怎么弹吉他。所以，我真的很怀念它。哇。好的。这太酷了。我是说，你写了一首歌还被收录在电影里。这简直太惊人了。太酷了。最后一个问题。你周末喜欢做什么？啊，这得看情况。我周末喜欢做什么呢，有时候我喜欢去真正的电影院看一场电影，周末喜欢做什么。有时候我喜欢去真正的电影院看一场电影。有时候我在背台词，这取决于我当时有没有工作。我还喜欢做什么？我喜欢填色。我喜欢填涂填色书之类的。而且事实上，珍妮·厄曼，就是
wrote our series, just sent me a box of wonderful pencils and coloring books because she loves to do that. And I have an app on my iPad that I love to do. I love to color. I love to listen to books on tape. That's one of the things I'm really starting to enjoy on my hiatus is that I'm now back to listening to books and reading a lot of different kinds of books. I just finished a book called The Conclave last night, which is brilliant. I know there's a film out about it. I want to go and see that.
我们剧集的编剧，刚刚寄给我一箱精美的铅笔和填色书，因为她很喜欢做这个。我在iPad上也有一个我很喜欢的填色应用。我喜欢填色。我喜欢听有声书。这是我在假期里开始非常享受的事情之一，我现在又开始听书了，并且阅读各种不同类型的书。我昨晚刚读完一本叫《秘密会议》的书，太精彩了。我知道现在有一部关于它的电影上映了。我想去看那部电影。
So yes, I like to read. I like the color. I guess it's kind of like a, I don't know, maybe I'm stuck at 13 years old. I don't know. But those are the kinds of things I like to do and be with my dog, my puppy, and just very low-key. That sounds lovely. Well, Kathy, you are such an icon of the entertainment business. You're such an icon,
所以，是的，我喜欢阅读。我喜欢填色。我想这有点像——我不知道，也许我心理年龄还停留在13岁吧。我不知道。但这些就是我喜欢做的事，和我的狗、我的小狗待在一起，过着非常低调的生活。听起来真可爱。好吧，凯茜，你绝对是娱乐界的传奇人物。你简直是一个传奇，
and I wondered if we could end the interview by asking you, what is the best piece of advice you received in your career? And what advice might you give an aspiring actor? Well, it all boils down to someone once told me you have to have a head like a bullet and a heart like a baby. And I could expand on that by saying especially nowadays, with social media being so powerful and powerful in negative ways is that you really have to be you have to get strong you have to get tough and at the same time not get cynical or bitter but you've got to protect yourself I don't advocate being on social media unless in your case it's a great thing for your
我想知道我们是否能以这样一个问题来结束采访：你在职业生涯中收到的最好的一条建议是什么？你会给有志成为演员的人什么建议？嗯，归根结底，曾经有人对我说过：你必须拥有一颗像子弹一样坚硬的头脑，和一颗像婴儿一样柔软的心。我可以对此做进一步的解释，尤其是现在，社交媒体如此强大，而且往往带有负面影响，你真的必须变得坚强，你必须变得强硬，但与此同时又不能变得愤世嫉俗或尖酸刻薄，你必须学会保护自己。我不主张玩社交媒体，除非对你来说，这对你的
show you need to do that. But I don't wanna read negative things about myself. I just think that the best kind of advice I could give is if you're serious about being an actor, if you wanna be an actor like Killian Murphy or Anthony Hopkins or Cate Blanchett, you have to study, you have to work. You can't just be, it's wonderful to be young
节目来说是件好事，那你就需要去做。但我不想读到关于我自己的负面评价。我只是觉得，我能给出的最好的建议是：如果你是认真的想当一名演员，如果你想成为像基里安·墨菲、安东尼·霍普金斯或凯特·布兰切特那样的演员，你必须学习，你必须努力。你不能仅仅——年轻当然很好，
and to be given an opportunity. And if you've got that spark, if you've got it and you can really sail out there, that's great. And then I'd say, protect your heart. Don't let your heart get hurt by strangers who say things about you or your work. Yeah. Yeah. Cause work is what got us here. Work is what kind of keep us here. I mean,
并且获得一个机会。如果你有那种灵气，如果你真的具备这种天赋并且能在行业里大展身手，那就太棒了。然后我想说，保护好你的心脏。不要让你的心被那些对你或你的作品指指点点的陌生人伤害。对。对。因为正是工作让我们走到了今天。是工作让我们在这个行业里立足。我是说，
it's like you guys were talking about the collaborative aspect of your work and that was the focus of what you did. And that's what made it so wonderful. Yeah. I love that. I feel like it's sometimes hard to be an artist, because you do have to keep that open heart in order to do the work. But that makes it so that you're, I don't know, it's, it's so easy to get wounded when you have that open heart. So it's, it's such a balance. be porous. It works great in your work, but it's not so great in the world outside. It can be difficult. But I remember producer, because I got very hurt one time in London by an awful interviewer and I literally left the tour. And I remember the producer coming to me and saying, you're gonna have to get a lot tougher. You're gonna have to toughen up, you know, and he was right. Anyway, I appreciate being able to chat with you in a very
就像你们之前讨论的你们工作的合作属性一样，那才是你们工作的核心。这也是它如此美妙的原因。是的。我太喜欢这个观点了。我觉得作为一个艺术家有时真的很难，因为你必须保持那颗开放的心才能完成创作。但这又让你——我不知道，当你拥有那颗开放的心时，你真的太容易受伤了。所以这真是一个微妙的平衡。保持敏感和包容。这在你的工作中效果很好，但在外面的现实世界里却不那么管用。这可能会很艰难。但我记得有个制片人——因为我以前在伦敦时曾被一个可怕的采访者狠狠地伤害过，我甚至直接退出了巡回宣传。我记得那个制片人走过来对我说：你必须变得坚强得多。你必须硬起心肠来，你知道的。他说的对。不管怎样，我很感激能以一种非常
open and safe way, and I think we talked about some wonderful things, and I'm so happy for you. Oh, well, thank you. Happy for you, Jenna, that you're, that you've come through this. Kathy, it was, it was such an honor to work with you. Yes. You know, You did something at our first table read together that I never forgot. You sat down at the table and you had the script and you got out a golden folding fan, the kind that you go like, and you would fan yourself because you were hot. And I thought to myself, You know? And I thought to myself, one day I am gonna earn the right to fan myself with a golden fan. And so, Kathy, my goal in life is to win a Tony.
开放和安全的方式和你们聊天，我觉得我们聊了一些非常美妙的话题，我为你们感到高兴。哦，谢谢。我也为你感到高兴，珍娜，你已经挺过来了。凯茜，能和你合作真的是太荣幸了。是的。你知道的，我们在第一次围读剧本时，你做了一件事，我永远不会忘记。你坐在桌子旁，拿着剧本，拿出一把金色的折扇，就是那种扇啊扇的扇子，因为你当时觉得热，所以你给自己扇风。我当时心里想，你知道吗？我当时心里想，总有一天我也要赢得用金扇子给自己扇风的资格。所以，凯茜，我人生的目标就是赢得一座托尼奖。
I want to do a Broadway show. I want to win a Tony. And when I walk up on that stage to accept my award, I am gonna get out a golden fan and I'm gonna fan myself in your honor. I'll wait for that. I really will. I'm excited for you to do that. Angela, thank you so much.
我想演百老汇演出。我想赢得托尼奖。当我走上那个舞台去领奖时，我要拿出金扇子，为了向你致敬，我要给自己扇扇风。我等着那一刻。我真的会等着的。我为你能这样做感到兴奋。安吉拉，非常感谢。
It was great speaking with you today. I really appreciate it. Wonderful. Thank you so much, Kathy. You're a light in the world and we just adore you. So thank you so much. Thank you so much for the opportunity You're a light in the world and we just adore you. So thank you so much. Thank you Cathy. Thank you so much for the opportunity.
今天能和你交谈真的很棒。我真的很感激。太好了。非常感谢你，凯茜。你是世界的一道光，我们都超级崇拜你。所以非常感谢你。非常感谢你给我们这个机会。你犹如世界的一道光，我们都超级崇拜你。所以非常感谢你。谢谢你，凯茜。非常感谢你提供这个机会。
Bye guys. Bye. Take care. Okay. Oh man, I just loved all of that. I loved just spending time with her. I really felt like we got to spend time with her. Yeah.
大家再见。再见。保重。好的。天哪，我太喜欢刚才的聊天了。我太喜欢和她在一起的时光了。我真的觉得我们度过了一段很棒的时光。是的。
And I just love how happy she is in this new job, in this new chapter of her life. You and I can really relate to that. Yeah. And Matlock, you guys, airs on CBS every Thursday at 9 p.m. Eastern, and it's also streaming on Paramount Plus. And it's already been picked up for a second season. Well, you know, Angela, we also said we would share a swipe up in our stories where people can learn more about lymphedema, and I would also like to include a link to the breast cancer risk assessment test. It is a test that you can take online at home to calculate your risk for developing breast cancer, and it's kind of based on your age, breast density, family history.
我太喜欢她在新工作、人生新阶段中表现出的那种快乐了。你和我对此真的感同身受。是的。各位，《麦洛克》将于美国东部时间每周四晚9点在CBS播出，也可以在Paramount Plus上观看流媒体。而且它已经续订第二季了。嗯，你知道的，安吉拉，我们之前还说过要在我们的动态（Stories）里分享一个上滑链接，大家可以在那里了解更多关于淋巴水肿的知识，我还想附上一个乳腺癌风险评估测试的链接。这是一个你可以在家通过网络进行的测试，用来计算你患乳腺癌的风险，它主要基于你的年龄、乳房密度、家族病史等因素。
And if you have an increased risk, you can share those results with your doctor and you might qualify for additional diagnostic testing. For example, if you are at a high risk but you're younger than 40, you might qualify for an annual mammogram much sooner. I have said before that my success with treatment is due to my very early detection, so it's really worth taking the test. Yeah, so important. Well everyone, thanks for listening today. We're going to be back with you on Friday with a special holiday bonus episode. Yeah, we can't wait.
如果你属于高风险人群，你可以把这些结果分享给你的医生，你可能就有资格进行额外的诊断性检查。例如，如果你处于高风险但年龄小于40岁，你可能会更有资格提前进行年度乳腺X光检查。我之前说过，我治疗成功归功于极早期的发现，所以这个测试真的非常值得去做。是的，太重要了。好了各位，谢谢大家今天的收听。我们周五将带着一期特殊的节日特别番外节目回归。是的，我们迫不及待了。
It's really festive, it's really fun, and we just hope you guys have a great week. Know that we're thinking of you, and we'll see you Friday. See you then! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer.
这期节目非常具有节日气氛，也非常有趣，我们希望大家都有个美好的一周。请知道我们一直在想着你们，我们周五见。到时候见！感谢收听“办公室女士们”。“办公室女士们”是奥德赛（Audyssey）的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的助理制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。奥德赛的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室女士们”由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。